à l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le laboratoire
d'histoire fête ses 30 ans et pour
l'occasion des étudiants ont réalisé une
exposition sur les affiches à travers
l'histoire contemporaine alors
l'exposition elle parle des affiches et
de l'affichage alors il y a des affiches
sur le 19e siècle il y a des affiches de
l'entre-deux-guerres du Parti communiste
et ici derrière moi il y a des affiches
des films soviétiques sortis entre 1986
et 1991 variés les affiches des peines
et toute une série de mutations sociales
culturelles et économiques l'exposition
s'intéresse à la politique à la guerre
ou à d'autres institutions comme le
cinéma mon travail portait plus
précisément sur ces affiches de films
soviétique je montre comment les la fin
de la censure qui a organisé par
Gorbatchev en 1986 fait évoluer les
affiches aussi bien que les films donc
les affiches sont des toujours
historiques intéressantes pour
l’historien ce qui est passionnant c'est
que c'est un master recherche donc on
est
encadré par des professeurs mais en même
temps on a beaucoup de liberté pour
choisir notre sujet de recherche
l'exposition aura lieu jusqu'au 2
décembre et un colloque sur les
nouvelles perspectives de l'histoire
culturelle se tiendra les 24 et 25
novembre